[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme on dit souvent dans la
vie le bonheur est à votre
porté chacun peut s'en prendre une
partie chacun pourrait en
profiter sagit tout simplement
comprendre que les plus belles choses ne
coûtent rien
le bonheur peut venir vous
surprendre n'importe où si vous voulez
bien c'est vrai
ça c'est vrai mais seulement pour que ça
arrive il faudrait que les gens arrêtent
de
chioler ça chle trop ça chle tout le
temps ça ch pour ça ch pour ça ça ch
parce qu'ils ont pas de ça ch parce
qu'ils ont pas ça ça ch tellement pour
qu qu'ils ont pas les gens même pas le
temps de s'apercevoir de tout ce qu'ils
ont
mais si les gens arrêent pas de chier ça
va être grave parce que je vais vous
dire quelque chose que si tout le monde
s'arrêta de chioler une minute et si
tout le monde prenait le temps de
regarder
autour je vous garanti ça chiolera bien
vite non ça chiera
pas parce que si le monde arrêtait de
chioler le
monde regarderait le monde et le monde
voirait le monde le monde voir toutes
les belles choses qu'il a dans le monde
des belles choses qui coûtent rien comme
on dit chez nous des belles affaires gr
partout a ple je pourrais vous enom j'ai
envie de vous les laisser trouver par
vousmême F pas ça vousz jamais vous enz
quelquesun parce que je sais la
télvisionrois je faire travailler vos
mes premièrement une belle chose grti
c'estàd qui coûte rien le soleil ça cote
rien le soleil le soleil luit pour tout
le monde le soleil dit pas oh non lui
les cheveux longs et pu
lui le soleil est comme la police il
frappe sans
regarder et la preuve Mesdames et
Messieurs que le soleil c'est gratis ça
coûte rien c'est qu'il y a beaucoup plus
de gens pauvres qui vivent dans des
endroits où il fait toujours soleil
qu'il y a des gens riches qui habitent
ici une deuxième chose gratice la
campagne entre nous mesdames et
messieurs il y a-t-il quelque chose de
plus beau que la campagne
oui la
ville mais la campagne c'est beau mais
personne ne profite de la campagne
pourquoi parce que tout le monde
s'imagine que la campagne ça coûte cher
allez voir les gens qui habitent la
campagne vous allez vous apercevoir que
ça ne peut pas coûter cher parce que les
gens qui habitent là campagne sont
cassés comme on dit chez nous ça veut
dire ils sont fauchés comme vous dites
chez vous même dans les vill c'est
incroyable même dans les villes vous
allez trouver des belles affaires
gratis je suis à Paris moi depuis déjà s
jour je suis allé partout et des belles
affaires gratis qui coût rien j'en ai
pas
trouvé mais si je
resta une dizaine d'années je suis que
j'en trouverai il y en a certains mais
même si j'en trouvais je pourrais pas
vous les nommer parce qu'on a pas le
temps l'émissionre seulement une
heure c'est vrai mais par contre je peux
vous dire que je prendrai le temps de
regarder parce que moi je ne suis pas de
ceux qui chi je suis de ceux qui regard
parce que je sais l'importance des
choses parce que je sais queux qui ne
s'arrê pas de Ch ça va être très grave
pour eux parce que ces gensl ne
connaîont jamais le
bonheur parce qu'il y a un vieux dicton
qui l'a dit je ne me rappelle plus à qui
il l'a dit mais le vieux dicton a dit
sans le bonheur tu es pas heureux non je
le sais que ça a l'air simpl mais c'est
très profond sans le bonheur tu es pas
heureux ça veut dire qu'il faut
connaître le bonheur et ceux qui se
permettent de
rire je pourrais peut-être vous demander
si vous connaissez bien le bonheur
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire qu'est-ce
que fait le bonheur dans la vie non
et bien moi je vais vous le dire avec
mon air simple le bonheur dans la vie il
passe si tu es pas prêt quand tu passes
tant pis pour toi si on veut le bonheur
il faut le mériter il faut se préparer
en conséquence je pense qu'elle elle l'
eu le bonheur parce que je te dis
que vous l'z eu le bonheur sair où le
bonheur ne va pas n'importe où le
bonheur n'aime pas n'importe qui
n'importe quoi n'importe quand le
bonheur va dans les maisons où la maison
est
propre il faut que le garde manger soit
bien
garni de préférence sans enfants et s'il
y a des enfants faut pas que les enfants
soient bruyants parce que le bonheur
déteste le bruit je le sais parce que le
bonheur a failli aller chez un de mes
beaux- frères c'est Man niè qui l'avait
fait demander
mais il est tourné à la porte parce que
quand il est arrivé là mon beau frère se
lança la vaisselle ver la coutellerie
avec sa femme tu sa une scène de ménage
qui appelle ça alors ça faisit trop de
bruit le bonheur est parti vous êtes
chané de m'avoir
ici parce que le bonheur je pourrais
vous en parler pendant des
heures mais les producteurs de
l'émission m'ont dit 5 minutes ça suffit
mais quand même je pourrais vous en
parler des heures parce que moi le
bonheur j'en ai entendu parler des
heures et des heures parce que ma femme
ma propre femme tu pas toujours PROE
mais ma
femme ma femme a connu le bonheur avant
qu'on se
marie le bonheur habitait tout près de
chez elle là moiême moi je l'ai pas
connu personnellement mais je l'ai vu
encore dernièrement j'ai vu le bonheur
je marchais sur la rue avec mon petit
garçon j'ai un petit garçon 4 ans comme
ça comme ça on marchait tous les deux et
tout à coup j'ai vu le bonheur il était
avec un jeune couple un jeune couple en
fait céit un garçon et une fille c'est
un jeune couple à l'ancienne mode disons
parce qu'aujourd'hui un jeune couple
c'est pas toujours un jeune garçon et
une jeune fille ça peut être deux jeunes
garçon deux jeunes filles une jeune dame
avec un jeune chien
bon disons que
c'était un jeune couple comme dans le
temp tu sais et puis moi quand je les ai
vu j'ai dit au petit viens on va aller
voir qui se passe là parce que je voyais
le bonheur rudder autour du coupe sais
puis tout à coup le garçon a pris la
fille il l'a plaqué sur un mur de brique
moi j'ai dit à mon petit retiens-moi il
va la battre lui hein mais non le gars
accroche la fille il se m l'embrasser à
pleine bouche et en pleine rue à flèche
ta flèche ça vololait partout comme on
dit chez nous ben moi je parti à rire je
disis à mon petit regarde regarde le
bonheur mais le petit il est trop petit
il l'a pas vu mais moi je riais mais le
jeune coupe pouvait voir par il é long
du M comme ça le bonheur éta en travers
de la rue alors il VO pas mais j'ai
tellement fort que le bonheur m'a
remarqué mais il m'a regardé d'un air
méchant un gros bonheur
noir grosse boule noire de
bonheur coup pas s si cé lui parce que
je sais pas où il Ava pass maisroch un
peu le bonheur noir c'est mais ça m'a
impressionné alors j'ai dit à mon petit
j'ai dit viens on lui parlera pas rien
on va rentrer à la
maison mais rendu chez nous je l'ai
regretté de pas avoir parlé au bonheur
parce que aura dû l'inviter tout de
suite à venir avec nous
autres parce que le
bonheur il est jamais venu chez
nous quand je me suis marié avec ma
femme on s'est marié tous les deux
d'ailleurs le même
jour je pensais que bonheur viendra tu
sais j'ai dit au moins il va venir à la
réception quelque chose mais je sais pas
si c'est à cause de mon beau frère qui
connaissait déjà puis qui savait qu'il
était bien bagarur pu tout ça en tout
cas il a décidé de pas
venir après que j'étais marié toujours
avec ma femme on est resté marié
ensemble on l'a attendu des semaines des
semaines des mois même attends attends
attends
attends c'est le petit qui est arrivé
là ma femme avec le petit ça lui faisait
beaucoup de travail les courses bon le
petit faire le
ménage et puis
fila pas comme on dit chez nous
fila mais filait un mauvais coton ça
veut dire qu' é
malade moi quand j'ai vu qu'elle était
malade j'ai dit
ressaisis-toi j'ai pas dit ça même je
parle pas comme ça chez nous mais quand
même j'ai d fais quelque chose le
bonheur viendra jamais dans une maison
où il y a une malade le bonheur déteste
la maladie mais comme elle comprend
toujours de travers au lieu de prendre
du mieux est
morte
bon ta femme
meurt ça dérange toujours un
peu pas longtemps mais pour quelques
jours tu sais trouve une gardienne
ensuite de ça ben la l'hôpital ça avait
coûté très cher alors j'ai obligé de me
prendre une petite job le soir tu sais
un travail
supplémentaire les fins de semaine en
français les
weekends tout
ça ça a été pas mal r entre vous puis
moi r ça veut dire tough vous comprenez
mieux non mais ça a été assez dur et
puis remarquez que là maintenant par
exemple je suis prêt pour le bonheur là
il peut venir n'importe quand là
maintenant tout est replacé puis de
toute façon j' que bonneur Vienne le
plus tôt possible parce que mon petit
garçon à 4 ans je trouve que c'est l'âge
parfait pour connaître le bonheur parce
que je me dis plus vieux j'ai peur qu'il
ait un peu de difficulté à s'habituer tu
sais puis
moi-même j'aimerais beaucoup que le
bonheur Vienne bientôt parce
que je commence à avoir des douleurs
dans les reins des choses comme ça
ah ben je me plains pas je suis pas fou
je le sais bien il faut pas se plaindre
parce que le bonheur déteste les gens
qui se plaignent mais qu'est-ce que vous
voulez des fois ça fait trop mal puis ça
paraît dans ce temps je bougonne je de
mauvaise
humeur
bonhe to que je vois
là je je vais m'en aller à la maison je
préparer un petit quelque chose à manger
puis je vais coucher le petit je vais
t'attendre
[Musique]
Okon
m'entends-tu je vais t'attendre faut que
tu viennes faut que tu viennes parce que
je pouris plus attendre longtemps
bonheur j'en peux
plus bonheur
vient VI parce
[Musique]
que